some big hollywood names are making
major safety moves in the wake of the
rust tragedy yeah starting with one of
the biggest action stars in the world
dwayne johnson and his production
company taking this serious pledge
moving forward we will not use real guns
ever again
we are going to be using
rubber guns and we'll take care of it in
post
and we won't worry about
the dollars we won't worry about math or
what the cost is i think we're going to
do it the right way the new protocol is
a major shift for the rock you know what
we should get this back in 2010 on the
set of faster he showed me a real gun on
set and followed appropriate safety
measures chambers empty
and angelina jolie who handled firearms
in salt and the lara croft franchise is
also speaking out after the rust
shooting saying quote i've always been
very careful because i've had to work
with guns a lot the way i've worked or
checked when i'm directing there are
certain procedures you have to take it
very seriously and armorer hana
gutierrez reid is doubling down on that
sabotage theory her attorney tells e.t
never in a million years that hannah
thinks that live rounds could have been
in the dummy round box i believe that
somebody
who would do that would want to sabotage
the set i think it's going to be a very
hard theory to prove out legal expert
rachel stockman says it all depends on
what evidence is uncovered right now the
attorneys i think are just floating a
theory in anticipation of possible
charges
[Music]